[Musique]
billets croyez vous qu'il y ait de pata
plus je ne vous trompez pas voter bien
sûr photo à
ouattara parce qu'au club attend the
hill on manque un
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est quel beau corps on
peut plus faire la sieste c'est bizarre
on qui détecte les
mais elle craint bien qu'on en fait à
son tour ce n'est plus possible
ils veulent une chips tout cas ce
monsieur bougon est devenu fou
réfléchissent à vauban oui merci
beaucoup monsieur moment vous n'avez pas
tarder à faire tant de bruit gamin sans
les propriétaires qu'est ce que c'est un
message à temps pour le jeu là là j'ai
faim je ne montais h chez moi ma grippe
coûte un juge à aller grave qu'est ce
que c'est contagieuse ça veut dire que
nous pouvons aussi être malade
si nous entrons chez monsieur beaugrand
plus pauvres il n'a rien à manger
j'avais dit ferrat bon bouillon et comme
un lit portera tu ce bouillon
ça c'est vrai
monsieur pouvant mahmoud abbas un même
support à mourir de faim tu n'as pas
hontes méchant comment va connaître un
deux trois oh ouais ouais t'as truc de
pata truc j'ai trouvé le truc hein
heureusement que je suis là avec cette
machine dont paquet iront jusque dans
l'assiette de monsieur beaugrand
il m'épate il est parti mais pas dit
combien faudra-t-il de temps pour
construire ta superbe machine pas
longtemps un mois ou deux je n'avais pas
pensé à ça patras 3 attendu devant
tremper la grippe ou faire sortir
monsieur bouton dépêchant d'eau
[Musique]
ses pattes vide à un panier au bout
d'une corde ça c'est un truc
bravo patins du oui à nice tu dans le
panier
un kilo de beurre 3 boîte de sucre 3
gros pain deux sacs de pommes de terre
un petit mode rien de qui le café cette
pointe et pinard 1 kg pisté trois îlots
de roche agglo titre aux vingt-sept pas
des pistes comme sa marque de chocolat
de 12 ou bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de
pas taper chez lui il ne faut trop
époque
notez bien sur vos droits d'auteur
pas grand chose à gaza ils m'ont
[Musique]